so I wrote a book you might have already
heard I've been talking about it enough
but one thing I haven't really talked
much about yet is how the book came into
being and I guess what on earth actually
is so that's what I'm gonna talk about
today I have come to quadrille to do
this this is my publishers office in
fact this is the very meeting room where
I had my first meeting with them where
they said hello
we like you do you want to write a book
and I was like whoa that sounds really
hard
I don't know but eventually I was like
okay let's do this I want to write a
science book which I think initially
they were a bit hesitant about because
science is a massive topic and a very
big undertaking especially for my first
ever book but credit goes to them they
were like okay let's let's give you a
shot charlie let's see where this goes
step one of actually making the thing
was figuring out the structure I wanted
to give people an overview of all of
science so I figured it would be best to
start with the very big stuff the
universe and then kind of work my way
down from there and that's how I came up
with the 10 chapter headings I quickly
learned that I am a bit of an over
writer so the first chapter of the book
was initially 20,000 words long which is
if I'd gone along that track the whole
book would have been like that big
fortunately I had my editor Romilly who
I think got rid of about half of that
first chapter and then also had the very
smart idea of making each chapter get
smaller and smaller as the topics
themselves were getting smaller to kind
of reflect the scale of the universe
which was a very smart way of her saying
please stop writing so much Charlie at
the same time that I was writing the
book that stuff was getting sent over to
fran and dave who were working on the
illustrations and design respectively
for some of the stuff in the book I
wrote little notes about what
illustrations and graphics I wanted for
example I asked for a personified
version of gravity that was also a
hipster and that's what I got but there
was also a good amount of stuff that I
didn't ask for that they just put in
because they're great for example the we
are all made of the universe
illustration which i think is probably
my favorite in the whole book Dave also
designed the cover of the book which was
kind of inspired by the index cards that
I have in the background of some of my
videos that went through
of different iterations like different
versions of the fun science title
different phases that I was pulling
after we did the photo shoot I did send
him my idea for what I thought the cover
should be that one didn't get approved
needless to say and now all it's
finished it's all done it's a real
bloomin book although I really do hope
that people who are already science fans
will enjoy this book the reason I wrote
it is because I want to get to the
people who aren't science fans yet I
want this book to be and kind of like an
in to the fandom of science and that's
why it was so important to me that it
feel like oh I could I could read this
it doesn't look too scary I think it
feels like that and that it's completely
down to Fran and Dave who just yeah they
nailed it basically if you are
interested in getting a copy it will be
out everywhere on October 20th
although check your local bookstore
because some people have already managed
to get their copies somehow I don't know
how and do come and see me on my book
tour I'm going to London Liverpool
Brighton Birmingham and Edinburgh and of
doing an event in New York City as well
so do come along all of the links to
tickets and things are down in the
description that's all thank you very
much for your support guys and I'll see
you again very soon good bye you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like who
thank you very much for watching in case
you missed it I also dropped the trailer
for fun science of the series so if
you'd like to take a look at that BAM
it's right there in each of the five
episodes is inspired by part of the book
and the first one will be coming out on
the 29th of October so until then tease
yourself get get teased up why don't you
that's all thanks again for watching and
for everything and goodbye